we have to start today by talking about
the veritable disaster that donald
trump's total miss handling of the Kurds
in Syria situation has become and over
the weekend we learned that Isis
fighters are now escaping potentially
reinvigorating Isis Trump has been
thrown into such disarray by this entire
situation that he's now making
suggestions as insane as oh the Kurds
are deliberately freeing Isis prisoners
in order to force the United States to
get back involved or to make him look
bad or whatever which is a conspiracy
theory that is absolutely without
evidence I mean there's just no evidence
for that period and it's quite frankly
an insane suggestion which we'll talk
about and in the background of course if
you are Russian President Vladimir Putin
and you're seeing what Donald Trump is
doing you were laughing all the way to
the bank if you are Turkish president
air Dewan and you see what Trump is
doing you are laughing all the way to
the bank
so let's first just reset here I mean
this is just such a huge story it's just
such a geopolitical disaster that we
have to have all the information and the
context Donald Trump teased a while ago
months close to a year maybe at this
point that he was going to get US troops
out of Syria good ok now any good
progressive wants to get out of so
called forever Wars out of military
engagements with no definite endpoint
military engagements of questionable
ethics and morality and practicality and
sometimes legality which often just
fueled the military-industrial complex
so no argument from me or from any
serious progressive in principle we
don't want US troops involved in any of
these places where it is not necessary
legal and all of the other
characteristics that we would want to
see now the concern around Syria was
that there was no particular reason why
it made sense at that point to get out
of Syria specifically because we knew
that our presence was partially to
defend the curve
an ethnic group with their own culture
and language who have been our allies in
the fight against Isis now all normal
disclaimers apply when it comes to
interventionism we can't be the world's
police we can't be committed
indefinitely to these engagements but
there were definitely places we could
have pulled troops from at the time that
made more sense and didn't immediately
and obviously put some of our allies at
risk of death and of course it just
stunk at the time that it was a move
that both Putin and our Diwan would love
for the United States to make since they
are a combination of anti Kurdish and
Pro Bashar al-assad so we were playing
right into their hands okay that was the
situation at the time so then it's quiet
for some months and then last week Trump
says we're pulling troops from northern
Syria but hold on a second Turkey is
going to attack the Kurds aren't they
they're going to get slaughtered why are
you doing this and Trump tweeted in
response to those concerns last week if
turkey does things I don't like I'll
destroy their economy I believe his
exact word what was that he would
obliterate their economy within hours
turkey starts bombing Kurdish forces in
northern Syria and all of a sudden were
wondering whose idea was this anyway to
pull out of northern Syria because the
State Department didn't recommend it the
military didn't recommend it we can't
find a reasonable answer to that
question other than circumstantially it
plays right into what authoritarian
erawan wants it plays right into what
authoritarian Vladimir Putin wants not
good as that gets us to this past
weekend the long weekend here in the
United States where we had the Monday
holiday and it is a situation of
absolute horror in northern Syria a New
York Times investigation by the way over
the weekend confirmed that in early May
Russian forces were bombing hospitals in
Syria to hurt the anti-assad movement we
know Putin wants to support Assad Trump
is playing right into that and the
entire region now has turned into
absolute and total chaos we've got
videos
of Turkish proxies straight-up
slaughtering people in the streets video
of people with their hands tied behind
their backs Kurds being shot now even if
you wanted US troops out and even if you
wanted US troops out now which is a
reasonable position to have there was a
right way to do it Donald Trump could
have worked with the United Nations
peacekeeping forces or maybe with the
Syrian government I don't know in
advance of just pulling out and could
have negotiated that there has to be
some force there to fill in the gap that
would be created by Donald Trump pulling
forces pulling troops from northern
Syria but of course that's not how
Donald Trump works and we now have 700
women and children linked to Isis who
have left the Kurdish detention camp
after an airstrike by Turkey dropped the
entire area into just total bedlam we
have a US official now who says that
Isis has a quote second lease on life
as a result of this completely
boneheaded decision by Donald Trump the
United States State Department is
acknowledging that have R in Calif the
civilian Secretary General of the future
Syria party which is the Kurdish
movement has been captured and killed by
Turkish backed Syrian opposition
fighters a Syrian Arab fighters have
been caught on video as I mentioned
shooting Kurdish prisoners with their
hands tied behind their backs and Donald
Trump is suggesting that it is all a
conspiracy Trump has suggested that the
Isis fighters who escaped were allowed
to escape by the Kurds in order to pull
the United States back into the region
Trump tweeting Kurds may be releasing
some to get us involved easily
recaptured by turkey or European nations
from where many came but they should
move quickly
big sanctions on Turkey coming do people
really think we should go to war with
NATO member Turkey never ending Wars
will end and there's a couple really
important things here number one there's
no evidence of what Donald Trump is
proposing here I mean there's there's
just no evidence he can speculate if he
wants but we all
need to understand that it's dangerous
speculation because there is no evidence
that this is some ploy by the Kurds to
release Isis people there's no evidence
of that
and number two we can't fall for this
never ending Wars will end thing because
that's not actually what this is about
this is nothing more than motivated
speculative reasoning by Trump to make
himself look less bad the world
community is perplexed by what Donald
Trump has done here in the United States
ranging from Republicans all the way to
Noam Chomsky believed that this was the
wrong decision and the news couldn't be
worse out of the region the Turkish
military has recaptured a border area
that had come to be under Kurdish
control Turkey now has it how does
Moscow Mitch McConnell spin this what
will loony Lindsey Graham or flimsy
Graham as one viewer suggested I call
him do now that he said Trump is going
to have to suffer the consequences of
what happened here if it all goes wrong
and it has all gone very very wrong
Donald Trump has effectively undone the
war against Isis here this is
potentially potentially a foreign policy
disaster that will rival george w bush's
decision to get into the iraq war after
a dozen and a half Saudi nationals
attacked us on 9/11 I don't want to be
hyperbolic I'm not saying it is that yet
but it has the potential to be and
Donald Trump is in his own world of
conspiracy theories and tweeting as
people are getting slaughtered within a
context of Isis being reinvigorated
maybe the the maybe it will rise to the
level of a George W Bush foreign policy
blunder certainly the biggest foreign
policy blunder of Trump's presidency so
far